foreign
[Music]
everything
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo welcome welcome welcome everybody it
is week 18
Ryan and we gotta we gotta we got a
different face today my man Michael
Ritter uh how we feeling today guys how
we feeling
today's a great day I mean today there's
never been a better day to be great and
finish the season off on such a high
note I can only speak though as somebody
who's six and two on their Best Bets I
don't Ritter can't I don't know if
Ritter can do that here we go I I hide
my picks I I I'm one of those Bettors
it's bad luck to put your bets out there
I'd keep them to myself and then
whenever I do well I brag about it and
whenever I don't do well nobody knows
about it that's that's the right way to
do it right that's what everyone
recommends
they they gave us an extra week of the
NFL season like this this season like
this this week didn't exist two years
ago last year was the first year of this
sure there are some games you probably
should not bet on but money to be made
today it's an extra week to make money
so I'm in a great mood yeah definitely
time for money to be made today you can
go win some money and we're gonna try to
help you win some money it's actually
time to build this parlay but before we
built this parlay I gotta welcome you
guys to the show because I want you guys
to know who is next to me you got a new
face next to me his name is uh Michael
Ritter I call him Red Dog next to him is
the guy
by the name of producer Ryan also known
as the man of the people that's I go by
two names
make himself the man of the people but
uh all right we're giving out our Best
Bets uh drop your locks in the chat
we'll be grading your picks at the end
of the show right now we need your help
to build our last regular season anytime
touchdown parlay Ryan tell the people
what we need from them we need your
Genius we need your locks we need
everything from you in these next 30
minutes but right now who's scoring a
touchdown today drop it in the chat we
will debate it we'll put it in if it's
minus 300 I will probably Lobby to take
it out but yeah we need three legs that
will happen I promise three legs and
we're looking to win and we're looking
to end the regular season on a high note
so uh but I will say there Ritter you
did say that there there were some games
that you probably shouldn't bet I would
like to tee you up for for some notes
you wrote down
so I'm a big Note Taker I got my handy
dandy pad right here these are the
ground rules today and I know I'm new to
the show but just a little background
I'm the guy that has to sit here and
watch these shows every week and I make
the clips and we do all that that's me
and my boy Bryson who's probably
watching it right now we handle all that
so we're gonna set some ground rules
really quick right off the bat there are
four games that you are not allowed to
drop in any time touchdown
bet from these games
this is these are those games bucks
Falcons Do not drop a bucks Falcons
player in this chat do not and I repeat
do not drop anyone from Texans or Colts
in the chat no one is watching that game
today if you have money on that game
today find God come back after you find
God and we'll talk
Panthers Saints stay away from that game
we are not talking about Panthers Saints
today
no Crystal Lobby we're not doing it all
right can't do it no Crystal Lobby all
right and the final game Chargers
Broncos so those are the four games you
were anyone else any other game you want
to drop in that's fine to repeat bucks
Falcons Texans Colts Panthers Saints
Chargers Broncos don't drop any player
from those games in let's roll Keenan
Allen no okay all right Raider broke the
ground rules we have to stay and abide
by the ground rules everybody fill up
the chat Philip the chat Ryan get in
here I see Naji Harris I see a lot I see
a lot of things don't be pushing
propaganda before we even start Greg I
see a lot of things here uh s riley99
Jordan Mason anytime touchdown uh for
those who don't know San Francisco 49ers
backup running back scores first
touchdown last week I love Jordan Mason
that will be yeah that's a good play yes
that's it no no no a great play Greg
that is a great play that is a great
play I'm not gonna lie uh I want to win
says Jalen hurts anytime touchdown I
think oh and then Le Baker says Richie
James I I don't know how many points to
John you're going to score today so
let's talk about right now let's talk
about Jordan Mason let's talk about
Jalen hurts if there's another one that
you guys see in the meantime uh tossed
it out I saw Kenneth Walker uh there's a
lot of people Walker chocolate Walker
what's the number on Jalen hurts what is
DraftKings giving us on Jalen hurts
because I think that's a good one to
talk about to get us going
let's do it because I see a lot of that
yeah
also shout out bagel and locks for
dropping in also he said only person
behind the scenes bailand locks does a
lot of hard work too but Zeke first half
TD that's still my favorite anytime part
of a part later we've ever given out so
and we cash and we cash
uh jalenhurtz minus 105.
for you I just I I don't know if the
Eagles right before the playoffs are
gonna be running their quarterback after
he just came back from the injury
against the team that has waved the
white flag today and says we don't care
about winning that's the Giants
organization by the way that's them in a
nutshell we don't care about winning
that's it
you heard it here hey what about
I see I heard yeah I don't know if I'm
in on Jalen hurts just because of the
couple things that we just went over but
I I do I do see Stefan Diggs we got beef
Thompson B Thompson 88 also laying land
22 mentioned Stefan dicks it's in a very
emotional game in Buffalo I mean uh that
the bills are going to be playing it's
in Buffalo
yeah I if we want to start this out with
Stefan Diggs I think the bills are going
to score many points today
I like this a lot I I completely agree
with what Greg's saying about the
emotional side of this and digs is kind
of the offensive leader of this team uh
when it comes to not being Josh Allen
and I again I think like we probably
should stay away from quarterbacks
touchdowns today like especially these
teams that are going to the playoffs
like they don't need to push it with
Josh Josh Allen has a rocket launcher
for an arm he does not need to run today
they should win this game I know the
Patriots are fighting for it Diggs is
probably the safest place oh gotta scoop
gotta scoop we gotta verify this scoop
of my man locks underwater said digs
touchdowns need it for Bill's record
he said Bill he said Dick's touchdown
needed for Bill's record uh that's what
we call a scoop Ryan that is what we
call a school scoop yeah uh we're in
Lock's underwater hold on lovely locks
underwater let us know what bills uh
what Bill's record will be broken if uh
dicks get a touchdown
um hold on one second uh bagel and locks
jumped in here because it's a it's a
play from the same game said Ryan the
rat let me get James Cook ASAP
Logan we just said nice things about you
I'm gonna disavow I'm gonna disavow
everything nice that was just said about
Logan he's my enemy now
welcome to the welcome to the enemy list
are you so bad Logan head over here
well buddy tough uh
yeah all right yeah we're waiting on
verification but but you're locking it
in uh Ryan yeah I think we're good with
this leg this is leg one in my opinion
up in the chat just to approve yeah I
think like I think everyone's on this I
think everyone's yes let's do thumbs up
in the chat if you guys like it uh in in
the meantime in the meantime between
time uh Ryan go look at that Jordan
Mason I'm putting my foot down I know I
know
I love it I love the Jordan Mason uh
play Jordan Mason oh please let me keep
scrolling please let me plus three there
he is
you're gonna make me sweat one Ryan
listen to me McCaffrey not gonna play as
much today no Niners are already there
you know what I'm saying they're trying
to save his legs next guy up Jordan
Mason
oh
I love this oh quick question Greg why
is
Corey Clement no Corey Clements on on
the Cardinals so never mind that's a
that was bad um here we go update update
from locks underwater record 11
touchdowns held by Bill Brooks so he
will break the receiver record I believe
for touchdowns if he goes score so we're
locking in Stefon Diggs I'm sorry Ryan I
I apologies I just have to let the
audience know why we were locking in
Stefan Diggs but what was your question
bro no no no no no all good I cleared it
up in my own head uh Jordan Mason if we
had Jordan Mason this parlay is already
at plus 778 and to be honest with you
this is all I've ever wanted on this
show to give to give me what I want in
the last week this is it I think this is
exactly what you want the the best way
we could possibly and this is a two-leg
parlay that gets us almost plus 800
value and it has Stefon Diggs and Jordan
Mason like that is the most if if we
want to Brand this as the Ryan parlay
which we've done in the past stop this
would be it right here
stop it two things uh no and second
thing we may not have Sam here but we
have Sam oh I don't know what happened
with the parlay uh we there it is there
it is it's still there
yeah no it wants to just lock in this
two teamer bro I don't know is is that
the box that we're getting that's not
that's not happening
but you're you have a little bit of Sam
in you in that you don't want to go for
greatness you just want you're you're
trying to settle here for two legs we
promised the people a three like parlay
and and DraftKings continuously wants us
to just keep placing this one which is a
sign hey guys guys guys guys
got another scoop got another scoop
Jamal Williams one touchdown away from
Sanders Siegel Siegel season uh Sanders
single season Lions record he's a TD
vulture gets a ton of touches near the
Golem it does
I
I don't know the only reason I say this
is because this game could potentially
mean something for the Lions so like
you're not gonna force feed somebody
when you may need to win the game
I hear you that's what they've done all
year I was just about
yeah I have another take on this game
though
tight ends for the Lions random tight
ends have been scoring at an insane clip
recently
do we no you want to toss in another
plus 370. I mean I'm not saying I don't
I'm not saying I'm against it
but I mean how could we like this is
this is going to be the game of the day
it is
Jamal Williams at minus 125 what does
that do for us
oh God
yeah this is
yeah I think bro are we just are we just
leaving Jordan Mason in this are we uh
is this like a bit that we're gonna like
we're committed to the bit of Jordan
Mason what's the bit I'm not gonna this
was it this was a lock drop in the chat
no yeah who dropped this in the chat did
you drop it in the chat oh accusations
of burners Jordan Mason was dropped in
here many I'll scroll back into it I'll
I'll do the dirty work here
no yeah I'd like to see what it is the
the people are asking the people are
asking I'm a Niner fan big Niner fan
here I I read up on the Niners daily got
Insiders on the Niners uh that are my
friends uh but
they're they're saying that my man uh
they're saying Elijah Mitchell was
coming back for the Niners today so
that's going to limit Jordan Mason
touches but
Elijah Mitchell is on the pitch count
he's going to have like five to ten
snaps maybe 15. so he's not gonna see a
lot of time here
so I don't know Ryan I was giving you
time to dig dig back to look for the fan
that uh mentioned Jordan Mason but I
just want to give that that perspective
to the people like Elijah Mitchell is on
the pitch count yeah and I'm as I'm
taking back that snake bagel and locks
dropped uh Eli Mitchell
so oh he he drives he dropped Elijah
Mitchell three minutes ago three minutes
ago I would have called him my king now
he's a snake that's unfortunate how
those things work but you got to be why
don't we it seems like the chat is very
Pro Jamal Williams and very where the
hell did Jordan Mason come from let's
let's can we just see what that looks
like if we take out our our good friend
Jordan Mason okay but again right it's
plus 236 so we need a third leg no
matter what we do we do and we said
before that's what we were gonna do yes
yeah
um I don't know guys jack cam Jack cam
is in the comments saying kiddo is a
better bet kiddo has been on in in
lockstep with Brock Purdy but
we maybe can find something better
uh I
probably don't want anything to do with
that
I know it wasn't one of the games that I
listed that are in our let's not touch
this but
I don't know I have I can't stay away
vibes from that one yeah you also said
Greg that like these the game might not
mean too much to the 49ers at a certain
point so like I don't know if I want to
have somebody who's like a a bona fide
starter I I really do think with the
Jordan Mason thing like Eli's
I agree I agree this is this is the most
anyone has ever talked about Jordan
Mason so we should clip this and at him
and be like hey listen somebody talked
about you today isn't this cool we'll
probably be Jordan Mason will want to
hop on this one day can we yeah let's
you want to move on did anyone else want
to move on is it just me
to to Jordan base to move past shorty
Mason you're saying let's move let's
move store to Mason that's that's what
I'm trying to say
let's do it we need we need another bet
we need another they're dropping locks
in like crazy and we're talking about
Jordan Mason like he's Barry Sanders 7.0
like he might be he might be a night
today he really might be I will say yeah
I'm uh whatever if we're God come on
I really liked that one
I liked it too right I liked it too it
not not even because I'm an iron fan but
because of the way the game is going to
be played today
you know you know if he scores a
touchdown you'll clip it out and at me
seven times and put the clown Emoji
we'll make that happen I'm I'm willing
to let that happen I and listen two
things I don't use the clown Emoji but I
will clown you that will happen Okay but
second I don't want to do that everyone
on this show acts like I like I want to
at Sam and let him know that he bet
against the cat well every time he bets
gets the Cowboys I think he wins but I I
don't like doing this
it's necessary I keep saying mild
Sanders miles Sanders miles Sanders I
see Boston Scott I see Boston Scott the
last time we ignored Boston Scott we we
have to get away from the idea that
these big names are gonna score today
most of them are not going to play or
play significant time hey I'm sorry
brother I get these oops I I just can't
help myself another school locks
underwater AJ Brown has a career goal of
1500 yards he needs 99. his line is at
67.
Greg this is a touchdown parlay it's a
touchdown yeah oh my God that I'm sorry
that's on me I'm sorry I'm I'm sorry my
head's all over the place I'm looking
for winners
Boston Scott
scored last time against the Giants too
Boston Scott
so there's a name that's been dropped in
here and I think Greg as a Bay Area uh
Native and I'm sure you're a fan of this
player that I've seen quite a few times
in here basically off the bat and I
think
jffl29 yeah he was the last one dropping
in nausea Harris how do we feel about
Naja Harris I will bring nausea here at
the beginning of the show
yeah
I don't know he's just been stinky poo
this year I feel like every time I watch
the Steelers Jalen Warren looks
significantly better
but I'm willing to talk about it if you
guys want
uh hold on I'm trying to drop some
propaganda here in the chat
okay go for it yeah
a lot of AJ Brown I'm starting to see it
I think that's just because we're
talking about him but I do see a lot of
AJ Brown Love gotcha uh all right
yeah somebody just dropped hey so we
just dropped Jordan Mason Ryan
I see Jordan Mason in the comments too
right I don't we don't have to say the
the username is not important I just see
another one another one dropped Jordan
Mason in the comments just like a couple
seconds oh my gosh that's crazy dude we
got two Georgian control we've lost
control we've lost control of the parlay
Naji Harris is minus 110. uh let's see
if we were to take out Boston Scott
which is also a lock
because uh it's laissez uh came in here
and and reminded me all of us actually
that Boston Scott always scores against
the Giants and the last time we didn't
take bosses Scott when it was dropped
and it hit this is plus 542. I don't
hate it outside of the fact that Naji
Harris is in this parlay that's the only
thing I hate about it but HD
I'm sorry I'm sorry no no uh
Greg this is one of the rare times uh oh
Trace said I'll hear another Jordan
Mason
stop talking about Jordan Mason Jordan
Mason trash
three says Jordan Mason for sure so I
guess you got some people yeah yeah yeah
see you're doing what I do you're cherry
picking the comments slim jim Jordan
Mason yeah yeah jodine Jordan Mason
Malin 102 Mason a lock yes sir Kyle
Summers from Andre Stevenson get out of
here that's not happening slim jim
Jordan Mason yes sir
it's a Jordan Mason day should we lock
it in oh how do we not I mean the people
are all over Jordan Mason
see here's the thing Ritter tried to
jump in here and he came in and he gave
all these bunch of rules he had a note
paddle rules and he doesn't realize Greg
we're the captains now he doesn't
realize
I I'm we are We Are Men of the people we
are men of the people so when we say
something the people who relax you know
what I'm saying they respond to it yeah
I mean Ritter you wanted to know where
Jordan Mason came from this wasn't just
out of thin air Greg and I didn't before
the show say Jordan Mason Jordan Mason
that was accepted you you went three
layers deep like in section and somebody
planted this and it's now going to be in
my head now I'm going to wake up
tomorrow morning and be thinking about
Jordan Mason and how if he scores a
touchdown today
Mason will play a lot in the second half
and he gets busy that's a fact it's a
fact it is I've seen it I've seen it
and I will say this Ritter you could
wait you could also wake up tomorrow
thinking about Jordan Mason and be like
wow Jordan Mason's now the reason why I
can buy a PS5 today right I mean that's
yeah that that is true
and we have this this is this is the
parlay I have always wanted for this
show this is
propaganda he saw it through plus 370
we're getting a 15-1 three-leg parlay
and this is this is all that Ryan is at
Sam is not here oh Sam Sam's in the chat
Sam's in the chat I know but like this
is this is I'm a substitute teacher and
you're just doing whatever you want
right now that's what this Jordan Mason
thing is this would never happen
Sam no I'm too much of a pushover and I
see the 15-1 I'm like ah you know it's
it's the the devil on the shoulder angel
on the shoulder it's like why are we
doing this please put somebody in the
Jordan Miss
I hey we're good on Jamal so all right
so then hold on I'm gonna ask the chat
now thumbs up if we're cool with this uh
thumbs down if we're not and if you're a
thumbs down tell us who you don't like
and who you would prefer to see in this
and we'll talk about I'm I will say the
first two legs of this I'm all in
there's been some names thrown out for
that third leg I agree if you don't like
Jordan Mason with a thumbs down give us
another option I am ready for I see you
Justin Jefferson yeah
you know I like JJ
I love Jordan Mason too though Ryan
minus 110. I mean like
I like the idea of us capping this off
with Jamal Williams on Sunday Night
Football I also really love Stefan Diggs
and
you know I I would tattoo Jordan Mason's
name on my shoulder at this point
I don't know if I don't know who we want
to take out here
mixed mixed results but there's
definitely more thumbs down than thumbs
up
uh is there
is debatable Joe Dean 75 with laughing
emojis and thumbs up emoji which sounds
like he's rooting for us to fail
okay
having a good time with the boys
laughing at the show laughing at us you
know laughing at uh create this parlay
talk about Jordan Mason
that's how I'm reading can we just see
what the what the Jefferson is if we
take out your boy Jordan Mason what
we're looking at there yeah let's just
see it trig away and Zibby both want AJ
Brown and
yeah
I don't know how I feel about AJ Brown
I like JJ I'm not gonna lie I like this
can we can we do like another parlay
with like Jordan Mason though
Jordan Mason and who was the other uh
Boston Scott what if we just did a
Jordan Mason boxes
Greg we had it Greg we had it
all right you know what I'm back on it
Jordan Mason Jordan Mason look at the
comments what what account
Jordan me
Greg I don't know if this is you because
there's three G's but uh Greg with three
G's Ivory so probably a you know
somebody who wants to be used
I thought I was verified but I guess I'm
not gotta work on that uh bagel and
locks said gotta remember Kirk might not
play with Justin Jefferson so I feel
like if Kirk's not gonna play there's
gonna be
uh why would Jefferson play for real
that's the also the other well I don't
know they kind of need to win no they
don't actually because they have no
tiebreaker
yeah they they don't win they don't win
any of the tiebreakers
it's definitely risky because it's this
is like a pre-season game for them
they'll play like the first half but
yeah
yeah I also
the Bears quarterback is not Justin
fields which means we will see the worst
version of the Bears they have a chance
to get the number one pick today I I I'm
I talked myself out of Justin Jefferson
I I don't know how you guys feel about
that I I don't hey yeah all right talk
like no JJ put Jordan Mason back in and
let's get on man yeah we'll get Ritter
Peter's about to lose it hey Ryan bro
you talk about getting rich since the
beat since the beginning yes you talked
about getting rich on this show
like almost since you've been on the
show like every week you come on here
you talk about getting rich me Sam we
always be like Ryan we're trying to win
we're trying to win we're trying to win
today week 18 the last week of the
Season Ryan
let's get rich
dude this is this again this is all I
have wanted this let's get rich Let's
Ride off into the sunset that is the NFL
playoffs on the highest note humanly
possible let's do it let's just let's do
it
this is it Zippy wants right you stop
them guess what man that ain't happening
I know Zippy I have been on your side
you were all locked in on the Jefferson
leg too Zippy I I I hear you your your
voice is loud in the chat right now but
they are it's it's two against one I
hand up I cannot endorse this that does
not mean I will not bet it I of course
will bet it yes but I can't I can't go
along with this Raider Joe Dean Joe Dean
75 says Ritter we need a public apology
next week when Jordan Mason scores okay
I will I'm afraid I won't be well
actually I will be on the show next week
we have a fun announcement about that
later uh and I will give a public
apology but yeah I see a lot of Let's
Get Rich we're getting rich fam let's
get rich
it really is substitute teacher I showed
up and you guys are throwing you guys
are throwing I can't curse throwing
stuff around the classroom and yelling
obscenities and yelling Jordan nation
and I can't I'm helpless yeah right as
we started the show it's like oh welcome
aboard welcome aboard this is going to
be so much fun we'll work at it together
and then Greg and I just stiff armed you
say let us cook in the chat I you can't
just say it was just the two of you the
the Chad oh no the chat loves Jordan
Mason the chat I I by the way
thank you chat for finally jumping in
here and being like let's let's take
this to the Moon let's do it if you
really wanted to get crazy there was
somebody that dropped in I I forget
their username but they dropped in take
out Jamal Williams and put in Boston
Scott so it's dig Scott and Mason
33-1 or something like that the onions
yeah the onions also just jumped in here
and said Malik Davis Jordan Mason Boston
Scott Malik Davis is the third string
running back for the Cowboys I may bet
that on the side I I'm gonna have to go
check what those odds are
retreat
s the week that doesn't make any sense
this is the week to go get rich
absolutely yes a week to go Rich week
18. hey Ryan
um I think you're looking up some some
odds but uh yeah
yeah I was I was trying to do the I was
trying to do the backup running back
parlay sorry but I'll I'll stay focused
uh yeah let's run through this
that's right let's run through it all
right leg one
Stefan Diggs anytime touchdown minus
115. leg two the Sunday Night Football
maybe Game of the Year Jamal Williams
minus 125 and like three some are
calling this the luckiest leg I'm
calling it the chat leg
Jordan Mason plus 370 and what are those
odds three legs plus 1481 this is the
week this is the week we get rich Greg
what is what week is this the week we
get what
this is the week we get rich yes sir go
yesterday
and we said that all year but I said in
week 18 Let's Get Rich Ritter let's get
rich Let's Go pump the chest Ritter pop
the chest
you hit me with hit him with the
silencer just a little bit
this is it my job is on the line that I
am going to hear about this in my
one-on-one
Jordan Mason Jordan let's go let's go
this is it make sure you guys tell us on
DraftKings and it wouldn't be a Sunday
if I didn't do a little anytime
touchdown boost magic so we're also
gonna boost we're gonna boost my man Joe
makes it anytime touchdown from minus
120 to plus one ten okay I like that I
like Joe mixon's from the Bay Area you
know we've talked about the Bay Area
Jordan Mason he plays in the Bay Area
the game's gonna take place in the Bay
Area I see the dots being connected I
see the dots being connected but also
also we mentioned Justin Jefferson
earlier in the show
Justin Jefferson needs 194 yards to
break Calvin Johnson's regular season
receiving yard record Ryan let's take a
look at DraftKings and see what it looks
like to bet on him to break the record
he needs 194 yards like you said
DraftKings and its weekly specials has
what they call the record breaker and
it's plus 650 today
click on that plus 650. if you like
Justin Jefferson today if you say we
don't know what we're talking about Kirk
Cousins is going to play all four
quarters they're going to feed Justin
Jefferson because that's just what they
do this is the bet for you to make
history today it's Justin Jefferson plus
650 on DraftKings
this is it guys
this is it
I don't know how you guys feel about it
I I already gave my team this is how I
feel about it I had JJ last week in my
fantasy championship and he did not show
up he could have he should easily have
this record easily have this record he
did not show up yeah but today is a new
day today is a new day
plan the Bears the Bears Past defenses
you know
maybe it might hit Maybe
uh Ritter you did this you did this with
Calvin Johnson week one I call him Cal
but you call him Calvin uh and he said
that this record may be broken in my
correct
yes no when we talked with Calvin
Johnson and we'll have the clip out if
if Justin Jefferson breaks us today
we'll make sure we run that back he
thought he said he liked both LSU boys
Jefferson and Chase he just thought the
chase would have a better chance to
break this because he has the better
quarterback
Kirk Cousins were ruling him out as like
a good question
but uh no he was he was very you know he
has this record and obviously there's
another game added but he was very much
like I want to see this broken like he's
he's very much a fan of this next
generation of receivers
um and I I personally I don't think
Jefferson breaks us today I think his
game last week really heard the chances
of this and Alexander played a fantastic
game I would not bet this today but if
you're a Vikings fan if you're a big fan
I just don't think there's going to be I
don't think he's gonna get enough
playing time to break this record today
and for that I am out
nice little sharks out yeah
Ritter is out hey but shout out to
DraftKings for doing this uh let's move
on to Best Bets guys let's move on to
Best Bets it's time for our Best Bets uh
Ritter how about you go first you are
the substitute today kind of but even
though you're not a substitute to us
you're here every day with us
behind the scenes in Louise uh you're
here today you're here the audience sees
your face today uh so you go first let
us know what you're rocking with
yeah so I kind of went back and forth
between a couple games uh for for my
best bet today and I really like there's
two games where there are teams that
have absolutely nothing to play for but
they're gonna play everyone that they
normally do and they're going up and
against a team that has to win and for
me I'm gonna go with the Rams plus six
as my best bet today I think that this
is a very important game for the Rams in
the sense that I think this is Sean
mcvay's last game as coach of the Los
Angeles Rams I think he's burnt out I
think he has done I think he's going to
get a TV job I think he'll be sitting in
the fox Booth with Tom Brady and with
Kevin Burkhart and that's the next Fox
Booth
um I think that his players really love
playing for him and I think nothing
would be better for them if they can
upset and ruin the Seattle Seahawks a
team that they hate their middle
linebacker uh Bobby Wagner did not end
his tenure very well with that Seattle
Seahawks organization he'll be motivated
and I also think their quarterback is
going to be very motivated with Baker
Mayfield he's playing for a contract to
be on a team next year it probably won't
be the Rams it might be the Washington
commanders for all we know I think this
is a very motivated very motivated team
and I think this plus six like sure the
Seahawks could win this game by a field
goal and they're marching on to the
playoffs and it's a great story I think
this Los Angeles Rams team will be
motivated it's the only time I've ever
bet on the Rams in my entire life as a
as a St Louis sports fan uh but I think
that this this line is too high and I
think again Seattle could win but I I
think this Ram team is going to be
motivated to ruin the Seahawks season so
I'm taking the Rams there it is my man
Michael Ritter locking and the Rams the
Los Angeles you guys see the r that
stands for Rams plus six uh
immediately
I mean this is this is like Logan this
is on Logan this is he just waged War
he did
that's a mistake do you have a pig
I mean it's unbelievable uh I will say
this I want to give it yeah a bagel and
locks us back in here with the Ryan the
rat this is unreal uh two things the
onions dropped the parlay I'm building
it on the side uh the Jordan Mason
busted Scott and Malik Davis anytime
touchdown parlay is plus 83.60 I mean
that is the get rich parlay of get rich
parlays uh but yes my pick kind of
coincides with ritters a little bit I
have heard nothing
but what the Lions can't do since the
beginning of the season right the Lions
can't keep up in the NFC North the Lions
can't win more than seven games the
Lions can't make the playoffs and then
it's the Lions can't play well on the
road Jared Goff can't play competent
quarterback in this league people forget
that Dan Campbell before this season on
HBO said this is the team that Ken and
this is the team that will and this is
the game where the lions jump in and
reminds people that they are that team
and that for the people who said they
can't you know they can't sweep the
Packers in a regular in the regular
season Aaron Rodgers is the re-l-a-x
relax relax relax they're gonna run the
table the Packers are gonna smoke them
on Sunday Night Football in Lambeau
Field give me the Lions plus five put it
up there give me the Lions plus five I'm
Mr six and two of my Best Bets it's
gonna be seven and two and this is this
I have the line is way too high way too
too high
yes
if you gave me if if the line was two
and a half okay maybe I wouldn't say
this and maybe I would drop lines money
line because that's how good I feel
about them winning this game but the
Detroit Lions plus five the team with
the most grit in the NFL the team that
is out to bust everyone's predictions
before the season started this is It's
the Lions guys I'm a Dan Campbell guy
thrown through I've got my big coffee
here uh this is just
I'm fired up about it I'm fired up about
it you're fired up Ryan I'm fired up
with you because it's my time to pick
all right guys you guys you guys have
two interesting picks before I came on
to the show I said uh guys I'm I'm I'm
I'm having trouble
deciding between two picks
and my two picks were
you guys picks
so guess what we're gonna keep the Vibes
going we're gonna keep the Vibes going
and we're going to connect the dots so
this is what we're gonna do I'm rocking
with the Los Angeles Rams plus six
and then Ryan you said the Detroit Lions
you like the money line
but you didn't take the money line no I
did
yeah that's rap that's rap Behavior but
that's okay anyway
okay I'm gonna take the money line
big dog behavior I'm taking the money
line I think the Lions can go out there
and beat those Packers and sweep them
this season all the turmoil Aaron
Rodgers has put that Lions fan base uh
in these past years he's been in that
Packers uniform
that's going to turn around today that
is going to turn around today give me
lions money line give me Rams also want
to touch on the Rams Ritter you talked
about the emotions McVay might not be
back next week next year Baker Mayfield
is playing for his NFL career there's
going to be a lot of emotions a lot of
emotions in that game I think it's going
to be a close one so I like the plus six
parlay both of you guys uh both of you
guys's picks and Ryan what what more am
I at with this one yeah yeah plus 422. I
mean there it is
there it is you guys talk about getting
rich
we are getting rich uh all right those
are our picks we all feeling good about
it uh should we grade some Best Bets
Ryan yeah that's great let's create some
bets if you want to you know drop your
Lions propaganda too I'll read that out
and we'll just we'll just all celebrate
it together but uh let's see
uh looking for a lot of people are
dropping rad emojis so I'm just trying
to get you know get through that oh
that's tough yeah yeah we really hate to
see that don't we
um
I wanted to shout out uh Dylan Wynn too
he uh whenever I was giving out my pick
he said all right Ritter it's not a
movie acceptance speech I love the pic
sometimes you got to just get right to
the point I appreciate the feedback
Dylan thank you uh
uh Melissa J said what was the plus
eight thirty uh 8360 parlay it was
Boston Scott Malik Davis and Jordan
Mason uh give me some okay that's right
that's Riley Jordan Mason anytime
touchdown
right
absolutely uh Mal said I would never
call Ryan a rat that's producer Ryan
respect thank you and he knows the bills
minus six are the best bet on the table
uh okay we could play the little
alternate line game here Bill's minus
six I'll go look what look up what those
odds are uh you guys tell me what you
think of it
yeah I would say I'm guessing that line
has dropped about like three points from
what it normally is I think that's okay
it's at eight it's at eight right now is
that eight oh yeah I'll go I'll go a
minus for that just just on the fact
that they are facing Bill Belichick and
their playoff lines on the line but Josh
Allen owns the bills like he just plays
crazy whenever he plays against Bill
Belichick so
um I'll give it an A minus for Mel uh
before you answer Greg those those odds
are minus 166. so you have a little bit
more of a clearer vision before you give
your grade
no I like it I like it I give it a B
plus b plus I I think that they're gonna
go out there and play Smash Mouth
football they're it's a lot of emotions
a lot of emotions that they're going to
be playing for uh their teammate went
down and they're going to be playing for
him so I think that they're gonna go out
there and put on the show okay uh Ryan D
says Jets plus three and a half
whoa they said Mason's at Plex 410 now I
love it oh yeah I mean
is that true
that's gonna make us even more Rich oh
we're gonna need an update on those odds
oh my God is that true
is it true did it go up no no no stop
lying in the chat whoa
bad Scoops Eric bad scoops
uh okay
again Ryan D Jets plus three and a half
what do you guys think
oh
I'd say no I was gonna I I was gonna bet
the Dolphins I was going to bet the
Dolphins yeah I said I don't know if
Teddy Bridgewater is playing I read
something I said Teddy might not play
he's gonna back up uh I think it's
Murphy or the quarterback the third
string quarterback Skyler Thompson yeah
Tyler Thompson yeah uh
Bridgewater is going to back him up so
that that that scared me that that
scared me from betting the Dolphins now
the Jets look tempting I I don't know
give it a Beat
they look Tim I don't have a I I have no
read on that game whatsoever so it's uh
as a substitute teacher you'll get a you
get a nice C plus as me doing the bare
minimum um is the pick that I'll give
out I like the fact that they're getting
a little bit more than a field goal I I
Skyler Thompson is a bona fide bad
quarterback you heard it here first
that's I know it's a hot take but Skylar
Thompson is bad uh and the Dolphins have
been horrible recently so uh I would I
like that I'll give that one a B plus uh
Dylan Wynn the guy that you shouted out
Ritter uh Pittsburgh money line as a
pittsburgher pittsburghite I don't know
how do you I don't know how that goes uh
but as a pittsburgher I need your guys
take so Pittsburgh money line he might
not like your tank Ritter
yes so Dylan this is great we're having
a nice Rapport here because I was going
to call you out too since you made me
laugh but so that was when I was talking
about the two games that I identified as
I like the team playing for nothing I
kind of like the Browns today just in
the fact that that team started to play
better the past couple weeks they would
love nothing more than to ruin the
Pittsburgh that's one of the most
underrated best rivalries in football
they would love nothing more than to
ruin the Steelers season and be the
first team to give Mike Tomlin a losing
record a guy that has haunted them for a
decade plus I think that that would be
really a good motivator for them going
into next season because I think that
team's gonna be good next year they have
all the pieces playing and everything
but my my reason why I didn't go with it
is the Mike Tomlin he's the best coach
in the NFL
um I think he'll have that team ready to
go and granted the Steelers need a few
things to go their way today
um I I ended up not taking it but I
think I would lean Brown's uh over the
Steelers and the and Tom one is the main
Factor why I'm going to stay away
like that like that Ritter all right
it's time to go make some money man it's
time to go make some money I gotta get
to the casino I'm pretty sure y'all
gotta put y'all [ __ ] in people you guys
watching y'all gotta either get to the
casino or put your beds in so uh it's
time to get on up out of here Ryan let's
review the picks today before we say
goodbye to the people yes sir all right
our get rich parlay is Stefan Diggs
anytime touchdown minus 115. Jamal
Williams on Sunday Night Football
anytime touchdown minus 125 and our guy
the friend friend of the show friend of
the show Jordan Mason uh front of the
show now plus 370. those odds are plus
14.81.
uh and our DraftKings Greg's magic
anytime boost is Jordan Mason to plus
110. uh love that
Joe Mixon not Jordan Mason if we were
given the boost for Jordan Mason to get
plus one ten I got Jordan Mason's so in
my head Joe Mixon Joe Mixon I can't stop
thinking about Jordan Mason I love that
guy Joe Mixon plus 110. uh that's
already time boost and then our Best
Bets Greg is combining R2 he's taking
the Rams plus six and he loves the Lions
money line because he's a smart man and
that's plus you're sorry too that's too
like parlay Ritter's all over the Rams
at plus six
and then we're really putting the rat uh
twice on this show that's interesting
that's an interesting take to do that uh
but my best bet against six of two uh
Detroit Lions plus five I love the lines
today and it's the native football I
think it's gonna be a close game but
that is our bets for week 18.
that's the bets man that is the bets
next week we're live on Saturday at 4
P.M Eastern to build a parlay and watch
the first game of Wild Card Weekend tap
in until then we are up out of here man
my eyes water and I gotta get up out of
here man peace
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]